>>> A FOX HOST SAYING THIS LIVE
ON THE AIR.
>> I WORK AT FOX.
I WANT TO SEE DISARRAY ON THE
LEFT.
IT'S GOOD FOR AMERICA.
IT'S GOOD FOR OUR RATINGS.
>> JOINING US NOW, CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR S.E. CUPP.
I'M FILING THIS UNDER STUFF WE
ALREADY KNEW, I GUESS?
>> YEAH, IT'S THE QUIET PART.
HE SAID THE QUIET PART.
I NEVER WOULD HAVE IMAGINED
CALLING JESSE WATERS A SCHOLAR.
HOWEVER, I THINK WHAT HE JUST
DID IS REALLY ARTICULATE SORT OF
THE THREE PILLARS OF THE NEW
AMERICAN RIGHT.
THE FIRST IS THAT THERE ARE TWO
AMERICAS, NOT ONE.
HE TALKS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WANTING TO SEE DISARRAY ON THE
LEFT AS IF IT IS SOMEHOW ALSO
NOT WANTING TO SEE DISARRAY IN
AMERICA.
AND NOT JUST IN A POLITICAL
PARTY, BUT WANTS REAL PAIN IN
THE STREETS.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE ARE NOT THE
UNITED STATES ANYMORE ON THE
RIGHT.
THERE ARE TWO AMERICAS.
ONE IS RIGHTEOUS.
ONE NEEDS TO BE SORT OF EXCISED.
NUMBER TWO IS THE CRUELTY IS THE
POINT, RIGHT?
THEY WANT TO SEE THE PAIN AND
THE DISARRAY.
THEY WANT PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN
AND AOC AND PELOSI AND LIBERALS
TO SUFFER.
THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
CHANGING HEARTS AND MINDS WITH
IDEAS.
THEY WANT TO SEE THE PAIN
BECAUSE THE CRUELTY IS THE
POINT.
AND, THIRDLY, RATINGS ABOVE ALL
ELSE.
THAT'S TRUE AT FOX.
CERTAINLY, RATINGS HAVE SEEMED
TO TRUMP PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ALSO, LIKE, FACTS,
BUT IT IS ALSO TRUE OF THE
ATTENTION ECONOMY THAT HAS
REALLY GRIPPED THE RIGHT, FOR
PEOPLE LIKE TRUMP AND MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE AND LAUREN
BOEBERT.
GETTING ATTENTION IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE ATTENTION
ECONOMY AND WHAT PEOPLE WILL DO
FOR RATINGS.
MARK GREEN TALKED ABOUT JOE
ROGEN AND HIS WILDLY POPULAR
PODCAST.
HE SAID ROGEN IS PAID TO HAVE
CONTROVERSIAL OPINIONS AND
GUESTS BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
REALLY LIKE THE FEELING OF BEING
INDEPENDENT FROM OR LOOKING DOWN
ON MAIN STREET PEOPLE AND
PERSPECTIVES.
LOOK AT HIM THROUGH THAT LENS,
AND IT MAKES SENSE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> SURE.
LISTEN, THERE IS NOTHING NEW
ABOUT BEING CONTRARIAN OR
SHOCKING, RIGHT?
WE HAD SHOCK JOCKS.
HOWARD STERN.
THAT'S A THING.
YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN A THING FOR
A LONG TIME HERE.
THE PROBLEM IS, I DON'T THINK
JOE IS VERY CAREFUL WITH HIS
PLATFORM, RIGHT?
DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC, IT
MIGHT NOT BE THE RIGHT TIME TO
GIVE MEDICAL ADVICE, WHICH, BY
THE WAY, I THINK JOE KNOWS IS
NOT SOUND.
BECAUSE HE SORT OF WALKED IT
BACK A FEW MONTHS AGO, SAYING,
LISTEN, I'M NOT A DOCTOR.
DON'T LISTEN TO ME.
BUT THAT HASN'T STOPPED HIM FROM
GIVING IT OUT.
LOOK, I DON'T THINK JOE ROGAN IS
CRUEL, LIKE ALEC JONES IS CRUEL.
I DON'T THINK HE IS MANIPULATIVE
INTENTIONALLY, THE WAY I THINK
TUCKER CARLSON INTENTIONALLY
MANIPULATES HIS AUDIENCE.
I THINK JOE ROGAN HAS A HUGE
PLATFORM, AND HE IS NOT CAREFUL
WITH IT.
>> ALSO, LET'S TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT CONAN O'BRIEN
SAID.
HE WAS ON HIS PODCAST.
HE SAID THAT HE WAS THINKING
ABOUT WHEN HE FIRST SAW JANUARY
6TH.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW HOW THAT
MOMENT WENT FOR US.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> IN THE BACKGROUND, I'M
WATCHING OUR COUNTRY START TO
COME APART AT THE SEAMS.
I SAID, "I DON'T THINK WE'RE
DOING A PODCAST RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT
IS ENDING RIGHT NOW ON CNN,
LIVE."
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT WAS INSANITY.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS THE
AMERICAN EXPERIMENT CRACKING?
>> IT WAS BREAKING.
LUCKILY, IT DIDN'T END, BUT IT
WAS BREAKING BY PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO BREAK IT.
LOOK, THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE THAT DAY WHO DIDN'T KNOW
WHY, AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THERE THAT DAY BECAUSE
THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD OVERTURN
A DEMOCRATIC ELECTION, SOMEHOW
PROCEDURALLY.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THERE THAT DAY WHO ADMIT
WANTING TO OVERTURN A DEMOCRATIC
ELECTION, VIOLENTLY, IF
NECESSARY.
THEY WENT AHEAD AND TRIED IT.
THOSE PEOPLE, THAT WING REALLY
DO WANT TO BREAK DEMOCRACY.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY JUST WANT
SOMEONE ELSE IN CHARGE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
IT'S THAT THEY WANT A DIFFERENT
TO GET IT, THEY HAVE TO BREAK
IT.
THEY HAVE TO BREAK DEMOCRACY.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO DO THAT
AND GO TO THE EXTREME TO DO
THAT, THAT'S REALLY HORRIFYING.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT JUST, LIKE,
FIVE OR SIX.
IT IS, LIKE, TENS OF THOUSANDS.
THEY ARE IN THE MILITARY.
THEY ARE IN INTELLIGENCE.
THEY ARE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE IN QANON.
THEY'RE YOUR NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR
IN SOME CASES.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT REALLY
BELIEVES THIS IS A CAUSE, IT'S A
RIGHTEOUS CAUSE, AND IT IS ONE
POTENTIALLY WORTH DYING FOR.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT WAS THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK -- I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS THE END OR THE LAST ATTEMPT.
I THINK THAT WAS THE BEGINNING
OF THIS ATTEMPT